I like going to the grocery store every two to three days
instead of doing a big grocery shop once a week.
Just helps me plan my meals better and also not waste as much food.
I always start off in the produce section.
It's my favorite section in the whole store.
I usually go for five to six vegetables
and obviously some herbs as well.
Lately I've been obsessed with tomatoes,
so I stocked up on those.
And always on some avocado
just to get some healthy fat into my diet as well.
For fruit, I get whatever I'm craving or the kids are craving,
but I always pick up bananas
and then lucky
wanted to try all of these different sodas in this queso.
I also stumbled across some Swedish candy
and obviously had to try that as well.
And we made it over to the deli meat section.
Got some salami,
some cheese, olives for the kids to snack on.
Since we still had milk and eggs at home,
I didn't get any of that.
I usually also go to the farmers market for those things,
but we didn't make it this weekend,
so the grocery store it was.
After this, we headed over to Whole Foods.
Forgot to get lemons and I wanted to make a recipe with lemons,
so we got that.
When I walk past this purple sweet potato,
I had to get it because I love doing kimchi with sweet potato.
They were all Sold out of a bunch of meat,
so I didn't really get as much protein as I wanted to get,
but I got some lamb,
and then we stocked up on some miscellaneous things. Also.
This yogurt, you guys is so good.
With all the baking I've been doing,
I needed to get some flour, too,
and this is what we got.
We got honey crisp apples,
some lemon oranges,
purple sweet potato and cucumber,
papaya herbs. So this beautiful tomato,
purple radishes,
mushroom, leafy greens.
Oh, cotto.
And then for dairy,
we got some yogurt,
Parmesan cheese,
feta cheese, and some cheddar.
Also got some dates and blackberries.
For protein, I got some lamb to roast deli meat.
We love trying out new salamis.
Been wanting to try these pickles,
so I picked those up.
And then I got a bunch of little random pantry items.